simone de beauvoir disparaît six ans
après celui qui fut son compagnon
pendant 51 ans jean paul sartre sur ces
images le couple en voyage à prague
ensemble ils s'étaient engagés dans
toutes les luttes de la gauche elle
avait personnellement ouvert la voie au
féminisme avec son livre le deuxième
sexe elle n'était pas mariée
et pour cause puisque elle parlait dans
cet ouvrage du lien matrimonial comme
d'une obscène institutions bourgeoises
avec sartre elle avait évoqué son oeuvre
parce que vous êtes comme moi vous
l'avez après terminé pourrait écrire
encore mais en gros notre vrai diable je
suis bien d'accord
alors donc on veut penser quelque chose
dessus on n'est pas en train de la faire
dedans on est dehors et les cliniques
alors qu'est ce que j'en pensais je
pense que j'ai réussi à peu près ce que
je voulais je ne veux pas dire que c'est
ce que tout écrivain veut et vous avez
vu d'ailleurs beaucoup d'autres choses
et donc j'avais d'autres choses mais moi
ce que je voulais essentiellement
c'était donc parler je m'appelle je lui
disais ça dans la vraie vie rangée
parler aux gens principe de bouche à
oreille parler de manière que les gens
s'identifient avec eux mais romero in ou
tirent profit de ce que je leur disais
et là je pense que j'ai réussi parce que
le deuxième 500 autres m'a valu
énormément de lettres de femmes qui s'y
réfèrent à existe vous avez aidé et j'ai
même vu les psychiatres qui m'ont dit
s'en servir pour faire prendre
conscience à certains de leurs malades
certaines surtout parce que ça a été
surtout les pieds aux femmes bon donc là
je pense qu'il ya quelque chose qui
était assez réussi et dans mes autres
romans et dans ma biographie aussi avait
certainement beaucoup de femmes qui sont
plus ou moins identifiés à moi ou pour
chercher en tout cas à penser une
certaine ligne de vie à partir de celle
qui avait été à vienne
castor comme l'appelait avec affection
sarthe fut la philosophe théoricienne de
tout le mouvement féministe elle fut
aussi l'une des égéries du saint germain
des prés de l'après guerre celui de la
trompinette de boris vian des câbles où
l'on se retrouvait pour refaire le monde
dans une ambiance de fête
c'est précisément dans ce quartier que
cette militante de la libération des
femmes aimées t'écris sur une petite
table du café les deux magots
d'ailleurs c'est avec un tableau de
l'élite intellectuelle de saint germain
entre la libération et la guerre froide
les mandarins qu'elle obtint le prix
goncourt en 1954
auteur d'une vingtaine d'ouvragés romans
essais théâtre simone de beauvoir
pensait avoir réussi à exprimer
l'essentiel de sa pensée je n'imagine
pas de m'attaquer à des ouvrages de très
très longue haleine qui me demandait sa
cousine on travaille surtout que je ne
pense pas que ça ajouterait beaucoup à
ce que j'ai dit je pense que j'ai dis
vraiment l'essentiel tout ce que j'avais
à dire
françois nourissier disait d'elle
éternel étudiante éternel révolte et
cherchant partout la misère cachée la
duperie la statistique sinistre la
rencontre enrichissante
madame de beauvoir peut nous agacer
parfois elle nous touche toujours